toute la bonne nourriture c'est toujours
bienvenue pour Noël non chaque année
Ursula vient en famille sur ce salon des
vins et saveurs de Poissy pour préparer
les fêtes comme la plupart des visiteurs
présents ce week-end sur l'événement
c'est pour la fête de Noël et du Nouvel
An vient acheter notre champagne en fait
il y a des produits notamment le foie
gras j'ai vu là qui est qui est qui
semble sympathique en tout cas entre les
escargots et le foie gras les visiteurs
pouvaient se rendre sur les stands des
producteurs locaux parmi eux ce domaine
viticole implanté dans les Yvelines à
d'Avron depuis 2017 il propose des
bouteilles à 23 euros à ouvrir pendant
un bon repas je vous conseille le chenin
en entrée avec les huîtres ou fruits de
mer si jamais vous avez la chance dans
dans déguster pendant les fêtes et
ensuite je dirais moi mon préféré c'est
le pinot noir en rouge sinon un
assemblage Merlot Cabernet Franc irait
parfaitement avec une dinde ou les plats
habituels les fêtes de Noël juste à côté
un biscuitier basé à Crespières dans le
78 depuis le début des années 2010
propose lui aussi des idées pour le pain
d'épice évidemment si vous avez du foie
gras et que notre pain d'épice est voilà
excellent
et après si vous voulez faire des
petites sauces au miel évidemment et
puis nos biscuits apéro pour l'apéro
quelques mètres plus long on retrouve
cette brasserie yvinoise elle est en
activité depuis 6 ans à Rambouillet
propose pour les fêtes une bouteille
pour l'occasion en cette saison on a une
bière de Noël donc une bière de Noël on
produit à peu près 1000 litres par an et
donc c'est quand la chance de la boire
c'est des privilégiés on peut dire au
total plus de 3000 visiteurs sont venus
sur cette douzième édition à Poissy ils
sont repartis avec des idées pour les
fêtes et un estomac bien rempli